15 years since the original you haven't
aged a bit is it your skincare routine I
mean that
was pointing at me yeah yeah a very nice
of you
is it like joining everybody again after
all this time being on set it's terrific
I mean for the longest time there was
talk that we were going to do a sequel
to Enchanted but it never really came
together and so we just all kind of went
on with our lives and some of us had
kids and made other movies TV shows
whatever and then it was like okay Adam
shankman came on board and I did
hairspray with him and he's like I think
we're doing this I'm like yeah you know
I hope so yeah uh and then I think just
the timing worked out for everyone on
board and all our wonderfully talented
newcomers and Steven Schwartz and Alan
Menken writing all original music I
think the thing was like what's the
story we're telling like and I and what
we explore in this is what happens after
happily ever after and where does that
go yeah
um so but it's got the same optimism
with the first movie and all the joy and
Magic
um but yeah 15 years later
2038
what is your favorite part about playing
a prince
my favorite part about this role is
Prince Edward and in this movie he's now
King Edward and Adina is Nancy Queen
Nancy of andalasia is I guess just when
you're given permission to be they're
always Larger than Life and over the top
and just you know not think twice about
it you know it's like my character just
loves being in love and loves the sound
of his own voice and it's just it's such
a great you know character to play
someone who's that sort of naive but
just innocent there's a purity to him
and you know every every statement has
to be sung you have to sing Everything
it's a great character to play and and
it's been fun to revisit him